- Hey! Schön, dass ihr da seid!
- Hallo, Nawin, schön, dich zu sehen!
Vielen Dank für die Einladung!
- Cool, danke schön!
- Prost!
- Was ist das?
- Das? Das ist eine Sehenswürdigkeit
in Köln: der Kölner Dom.
Warst du schon mal in Köln?
Kennst du die Stadt?
- Nein.
- Warst du noch nie in Deutschland?
Oder in Österreich oder in der Schweiz?
- Jetzt habe ich Geschenke aus Köln,
Hamburg, Düsseldorf, Heidelberg und Berlin.
- Und welche Städte kennst du schon?
- Ich war schon mal in Hamburg und in Köln.
In Heidelberg war ich noch nie.
Nächste Woche fahre ich nach München!
- Was ist das?
- Das ist das Brandenburger Tor.
Eine Sehenswürdigkeit in Berlin.
- Kennst du Berlin?
- Nein. Aber Nina war schon mal in Berlin.
Und Sebastian.
Ihr wart schon mal in Berlin, oder?
- Wir beide waren schon mal in Berlin, ja.
Wir waren sogar am Brandenburger Tor.
- Nico?
- Hm …
- Alles gut?
Kein Kommentar?
Komm! Wir spielen ein Spiel.